I feel like black is doing quite nicely
look at this activity for the pieces oh
G5 fell off but was that a blunder or a
sacrifice
yeah because he didn't move instantly I
think it was a blunder but I mean he did
find something out of that he's still
doing oh my goodness he's in here for
the win we don't ever have to play
another opening King's Indian for the
win once again can we get some kid in
the chat he's Indian defense I'm always
a special
let's move some King zillion in the chat
who likes King's Indian defense this
one's a wrap if that Queen is trapped
let's go up to E2 then you force the
Queens off you win the ensuing endgame
Magnus Agnes is back
slip but if you take this bishop on C3
then white takes the Knight on E7 and
then there's Nike G5 ideas that King is
into trouble and now B7 is gone that
gives way to pass oh my goodness bro
it's about to be a 2-0 frozen relax you
know this Magnus right like you know
this is magnet I don't know if you know
that I like Magnet or else it's maybe
he's winning now there it is yeah best
chess players in history a former World
Blitz Champion uh he's had so many
successes to his name but he's rooting
for his compatriot that all there is a
fruit bam Bishop H2 check will follow if
the Knight where to move so Ali rizz
just won a piece he's probably thanking
his friend Maxime for stopping by
foreign
look at that Magnus getting Magnus you
know what I mean like when do you ever
see that Magnus getting Magnus in the
end game right now they still chances
for a draw Still chances very difficult
yeah you know what you just can't do
just move that's all you have to do if
you're Max look at the clock I don't
think alireza has enough time to convert
this advantage
it's a moment of silence right now I'm
about to go live like silent like I
gotta see if he's gonna convert this oh
man check move okay yeah yeah Knight G4
doing good
he's almost there Magma's paused which
was probably not a good one to be there
at that moment oh now farooza has it
he's mating oh my goodness this guy is
unreal four seconds here remove Primo
pre-move everything removed oh no yeah
he's gone oh
oh what is gonna happen oh he Flags he
hits the table he smiles all this about
to get seriously and that's why he's
giving away pieces but we do see that
magnet oh my gosh he's moving too slowly
he takes the queen but he's a little
time
into a check now the black king is
hunted Queen G7 Queen takes F7 there's
probably other things oh Bishop C6 is
even go for the check just yet
wow because he wants queen D5 after all
right
be blundered and a lot of Queen trade
geez
oh no all his pieces are gone and he's
mad he's very very mad I think he's
trying to convince himself that he can
do this by shaking the clock and then
you need a mouse right so like it's
different that's just so funny extra
piece there whoa what happened what the
hey bro what noise
he's in pain yeah it really is and I
think he's in pain because he trades
when he's ahead like his coaches always
tell him and somehow that was a bad it
was a rook at fate in Bishop C5 I guess
not
yeah not anymore here he's worth walking
the King around he's winning F5 is going
to come with the check
before F5 check take take and we push
yeah and we push walk the dogs in the
park very easy push push push push
and that's that Magnus he throws in the
towel he's down five seconds and come
pawns I mean he really is in pain right
now you can see it yeah on his face I
think some people nice sacrifice we got
in an aggressive position here
it is
that is maybe the move of the day if you
take with the Knight F7 Falls if you
took with a bishop checkmate on d8 so he
was rookie seven but now this bishop is
pinned and that's amazing here as well
that's my first arrows of the day that's
how good the move was
okay
oh yeah
I love that he does a lot of those he
you know we've seen him do when he used
to stream we would see him do puzzles
and just blow through puzzles on nice to
do
and now it's under 10 minutes remaining
so Magnus he needs to catch up it is Win
body get those Knights off the board and
there they go but this outside pass Pawn
it's a straggler it's by itself it
doesn't have a companion but that's
checking one oh my goodness Magnus
Carlson hangs mate in one and this oh
he's
made it he's even saying that it's done
that's game that's match fine bro on
fire